ce sera le site de recherche et
développement d'atos aux
clayes-sous-bois le bâtiment diane 8000
m² dédié à l'innovation un
investissement de près de 5 millions
d'euros
ce sont des machines de recherche
développement fonctionnel et qui
permettront à la direction recherche et
deux blancs de pouvoir présenter alors
qu'on devait protéger au client les
différentes machines existantes ou
développé pour le compte et la structure
sur deux étages accueillera entre 400 et
450 collaborateurs
une centaine seront embauchés deux tiers
seront des ingénieurs de recherche et
développement donc ici une succession de
meeting room à cet endroit là ensuite la
bibliothèque et les spas je dirais de
coworking
l'objectif c'est de créer aussi un
acteur de ce centre des espaces de
partage des endroits où les gens ne
pouvoir se regrouper et puis on va
essayer de travailler dans une vision
plutôt systémique des sites des deux de
nos machines de nos serveurs de nos
super calculateur de notre sécurité
plutôt que sur une vision très si l'hôte
et des supercalculateurs informatique
l'ordinateur quantique la cyber sécurité
des innovations de rupture les futurs
thématiques de recherche notamment les
ingénieurs travailleront sur l'avenir de
la quantum learning machine c'est une
machine qui simule le comportement d'un
ordinateur quantique sans avoir
d'ordinateurs quantiques sans avoir de
qubits et ça c'est vraiment très très
utile parce que ça permet de tester le
comportement d'algorithmes qu'anti que
l'on développe et que l'on fait tourner
et ça permet de se préparer
la fin des travaux est prévue à l'été
2001 le déménagement des équipes sera
étalée sur le deuxième semestre de
l'année